please welcome
the queens of the home and my dear
friends cleo shearer and joanna teplin
[Applause]
thank you
um
in honor of our collaboration and our
blossoming friendship which i'm so
grateful for you guys are gonna give us
three spring cleaning tips um for three
different rooms in your house and first
up i think you guys have the bedroom yes
so take it away okay we're gonna show
you how to fold it is a very common
thing that people my daughter for
instance is terrible at it this is her
idea of folding so you know and it's a
lot of people's idea folding so what you
want to do is you want to start put the
shirt face down
and then it's really simple it's a file
folding method so that you can see every
single thing that you have
and you just instead of a pile where you
can't see anything under that's right
so you just fold it like this
and then what you want to do is a
trifold you bring it up
and then you bring it up like that the
trifold yeah that's the difference and
if you want by the way if you have a
drawer that can you can i like this
that's my favorite part yes it's very
satisfying you can do a tuck and you
just basically you know you put it right
in just like that and joanna if you want
to put your
banana white here yes this is a drawer
divider which is so helpful as far as
keeping items in place without them
moving too much so after you say you
have all your short sleeve t-shirts you
could then add the drawer divider and
just lock it into place right and then
have all say your long sleeve t-shirts
here so then you always know when you
open the drawer exactly what you have
and actually i think one of these
drawers is already here we go oh this is
what it looks like
all nicely folded
and it's so easy honestly it's so easy
i know and you can see everything
without having to you know pull from the
middle of a stack and everything falls
over right and of course we like to
rainbow five everything if possible um
so a little roy g biv never hurt anyone
and you know you can find exactly what
you're looking for oh i need a blue
shirt today well guess it's what's in
the blue side right and your whole
drawer then stays in place as opposed to
just all this and then your piles are
everywhere all right next we're going to
head over to death okay next is the desk
and office set up you guys i mean dot oh
desk set i know i mean my desk is um
well it's ridiculous
so i'm very curious about this okay okay
because i got no dust game okay the best
one of the best things you can do is to
get just a portable um drawer
file folder thank you thank you filebox
yep and you want to just file away you
know important documents into one file
and then you can put you know if we have
receipts or something laying around you
can put those in a different file and
then you just want to label each file so
that when you go to look for something
it's so easy and right there a color
coded system can be really helpful yeah
you can have like your auto your home
your work you know whatever it may be
right and that way you're not just
overwhelmed with piles again it's the
piles that are the problem and let me
ask you a question because i immediately
go to funny enough we have an example
right here now
this
just
tell me what i should do in this okay
and you might tell me this isn't for
that right what if you have different
size papers sure okay well this in
particular is more sentimental items
these are special things that cards
people have made for you things that you
really want to hold on to yeah kids are
that's right great shoe boxes
opaque boxes that's right
you want to hold on to them but what we
call a file box is for touch access
things that you need to get to bills
you know things that you actually need
to be filing and looking up okay
sentimental items are things that on a
rainy day maybe you want to take the box
down and go through it and look at it
right picture special special memories
that way they're nice and tidy pretty i
know and then you can go with them on a
rainy day and look at all the beautiful
artwork that your kids are friends with
set them up for your kids too
yes
so
another thing that tends to really
perplex people these days is what to do
with all of your cords and cables
charging stations are a big one um this
is a cord wrap it's amazing it's magical
yeah um and honestly all you do at the
end of the day
is you just you twist it and then you
keep all of your cables together without
making a giant it's a little gift for
you when you're looking to charge
anything and another thing you can do if
you want for instance if you want to
actually set up a docking station you
can use a bin with a handle have the
cord plugged in and then all of your
items can sit in a bin out of sight and
it doesn't have to be taking over
everywhere
[Music]